6 15 here on a thursday morning and we
are approaching nascar weekend here in
town and we've got ron futrell joining
us live in an rv at the las vegas motor
speed oh he's out of the rv good morning
ron good morning sunshine knocking on my
door like that armando come on now you
knocking on my door waking me up that
early i'm trying to get okay oh we live
are we we're here oh okay hey i have a
new nickname in the morning okay that i
want you to call me
can i go with road wire what's my new
name here in the morning will you do
that armada wake me up this early in the
morning i'm barely out of well i'm still
in my thank goodness and my polar bear
jammies here but yes it is sunrise at
the speedway it is looking nice out here
today i'm going to have some neighbors
stop by in a little bit today that'll be
fun out here now we're in the motorhome
of course having fun that's part of the
culture part of the nascar culture are
the motor homes that hang out here on
the infield at racetracks all over the
country they're doing it this week we
talked with one driver jordan anderson
who understands and really appreciates
this motorhome culture
we hooked up with uh dometic here i know
we're here at johnny walker rv uh it's a
it's a great place to be but you know
that's one thing with the racing world
you go to any race track here and see
tons of motor homes tons of rvs those
are some die hard fans they get out
there on wednesday thursday they're
there for the whole weekend and that's
the whole backbone of our sport fans
that travel i mean you're gonna have
fans that were in california last week
at auto club they're here in vegas
they're going to phoenix next week
they're going to hit all three races
they love the sport and they love the
culture
yes indeed okay some of the things going
on today will be fun to be able to check
out
you i've got to get more neighbors today
because the xfinity which is the minor
league for nascar their haulers are
going to be coming in here around noon
we're also going to have oh the hauler
parade the nascar hauler parade down on
the strip it begins at six o'clock just
outside the luxor and then it comes all
the way here and at seven o'clock it
really gets loud
here at the speedway as things start
happening here tonight so that's going
to be fun and there's also some events
later tonight we'll talk about that in
my next hit and tell you a little bit
about some of the events djs are going
to be out here and some golf and other
things that will be happening out here
at the speedway but reporting live from
las vegas motor speedway bright and
early in the morning i'm road warrior
remember my new name okay don't forget
it in the morning warrior we're gonna
get some pants road warrior live local
now
all right maybe some pomade too for that
head
that would work ron we'll catch up with
you later on we're debating whether we
should keep the road warrior name you're
suggesting or the pajama pants pajama
pants future
pajama pants pajamas polar bear yeah
polar bear polar bear yeah it works it
fits
thanks ron we'll catch up with a little
bit six